sommes-nous à Marseille ou en Colombie
socaina une étudiante en droit de 24 ans
a été tué dimanche soir par une balle
perdue de kalachnikov qui a traversé le
mur de son appartement du 3e étage le
projectile lui a perforé le crâne au
moment où elle était dans sa chambre à
côté de sa mère Leila le drame s'est
produit à Marseille dans la cité Santis
lorsque des voyous équipés d'armes de
guerre ont tiré sur une pharmacie avant
de raffaler à l'aveugle la façade d'un
immeuble ma fille vanne de passer
prendre son café et deux secondes après
je l'ai trouvé dans sa chambre avec la
tête explosée il y avait du sang partout
je n'ai pas compris je n'arrive pas à
comprendre je n'ai jamais vu ça c'est en
France que ça se passe même en Colombie
on ne voit pas ça 44 morts et 109
blessés voici le vertigineux bilan des
règlements de comptes à Marseille depuis
janvier 2023 en neuf mois plus de 600
armes ont été saisis dont 53 fusils
d'assaut une hausse de 83% désormais la
procureur de Marseille parle de
narcomicide selon le ministre de
l'Intérieur les salves mortelles de
kalachnikov s'expliquent par le travail
très important que fait la police pour
éradiquer les points de Deal ce qui
oblige les trafiquants à chercher
d'autres endroits où s'implantés
notamment des secteurs jusqu'ici peu
criminogènes résultat le fait de police
de Marseille Frédéric Camilleri a décidé
de compter depuis janvier 2022 sans
exception tous les homicides des
tentatives qui se rapportent au point de
l'île au trafiquant mais aussi au
revendeur qui peuvent eux aussi tomber
sous les balles l'ampleur des moyens mis
en place à Marseille et colossal 400
policiers déployés dans les quartiers
entre 2021 et 2024 un renfort de 26
membres de la police judiciaire une
nouvelle unité de crs8 dès novembre 2023
un nouveau commissariat dans le quartier
Nord en 2024 ainsi qu'un nouvel hôtel de
police en 2027 toutes ces actions ont
permis de réduire de 43% le nombre de
points de deal en tout 70 supermarchés
de la cam ont été éradiquées en moins de
deux ans et malgré de bons résultats les
policiers sont confrontés à une hausse
de la violence difficilement contrôlable
selon Gérald Darmanin la seule solution
pour empêcher la pieuvre de s'agrandir
c'est l'attaque des organisations
criminelles et certainement pas la
légalisation qui partout où elle a été
adoptée complète le marché illégal mais
ne le remplace pas